So let's look at the AMAT equation
when we have a cache hierarchy.
The AMAT is still equal
to L1 hit time plus
the L1 miss rate times the L1 miss
penalty, but it used to stop here and
the L1 miss penalty would simply
be the memory access time.
But now we have that the L1
miss penalty is the L2 hit time
plus the L2 miss rate times
the L2 miss penalty and
the L2 miss penalty is the L3
hit time plus the level 3
miss rate times the level 3 miss
penalty and so on until at some point,
we have a cache whose miss
penalty is equal to the main
memory latencies because there
is no more caches beneath it.
This cache whose misses go
directly to memory is called
the last level cache, or LLC.
So it used to be that the L1 cache was
the only cache, so L1 cache was the LLC.
Then level 2 cache's were introduced so
level 2 miss penalty was the main
number latency because level
2 went directly to memory and
that was the last level cache and
then level 3 cache's were introduced so
they became the LLC and so on.